who will be very happy to answer our
questions I didn't really plan for 50
minutes so I do hope there will be
questions I desperately hope there will
be questions the title of the talk is a
bit of a mouthful a simple condition for
constant we go at an online decision
making I actually want to replace
constant regret by uniform loss sit
refers to the regret language I'm a
little bit hesitant to use the word
regret because then people think of
bandits and this is not about bandits
though it is about online decision
making and I sort of want to say pick
your favorite online decision making
problem so online bin packing would be
one problem that we can tackle using our
sufficient condition online network
revenue management would sort of be the
one where the idea originally came from
in a former paper upsets we're gonna
have a running example of an online job
allocation problem that I'm going to
define in a little bit all of these very
very easily fall into the framework that
I'm going to describe now the online
decision-making world that we're living
in is one with a long but finite time
horizon and in each iteration there's
some random arrival right now I assume
that I have coin tosses but they don't
need to be cantos us it's just some type
shows up in each iteration and I know
the distribution that shows up and I
then need to take an action that again
right now I assume there are just two
actions there can be any number of
actions and in the end at the end of the
time horizon
we're gonna have a function f that we're
trying to minimize and F is a function
of all our actions but it's really just
a function of how often did we take each
action for each arrival type so if you
think of the action being either accept
or reject
then I don't care when you accept it or
when we accept it a particular type
I only care about how often did we
accept each type now what is our
benchmark what do we compare ourselves
to as I said we know the distribution of
arrivals for each of the independent
arrivals that occur our benchmark will
be the clairvoyant offline optimal so we
compare ourselves with and with with
somebody who knows the exact outcome who
knows the exact arrivals that occur in
every single iteration so this is sort
of an MDP setting it's not as I said any
sort of bandit or adversarial setting
but I do want to highlight that our
offline our offline benchmark here is
better than the optimal solution so the
optimal solution still needs to somehow
cope with the randomness that occurs in
the problem whereas our benchmark
actually doesn't need to deal with
randomness our benchmark knows exactly
what's happening so we want to get
uniform loss so we want to minimize the
expected difference expectation being
taken over the random arrivals off the
objective value that the algorithm gets
we're not going to define our algorithm
for a very long time but we want to
minimize the expected loss between the
algorithm and the clairvoyant offline
optimal and when we say uniform what we
mean is we wanted to be independent of
the time horizon
now the piece I want to highlight is
even with infinite computing power it's
not a priori clear that this would be
possible so given that offline is a
better benchmark than the optimum even
if you ignore any sort of curse of
dimensionality even if you ignore the
fact that we may not be able to compute
the optimum we would still not
necessarily be able to get a uniform
loss simply because our benchmark is
quite a bit stronger so in the landscape
of online decision-making problem we
have the optimistic extreme which would
be the approximate dynamic programming
reinforcement learning we can learn
optimal policies using huge amounts of
huge amounts of data and computation and
on the other end we arguably have the
pessimistic extreme that we can't use
any that we don't have any historical
data at all to learn from and we are in
the adversarial context we are really in
the middle ground where we have data to
base it on but we don't have the
infinite amount of data so our informal
result is then and this is really a very
informal way of stating it as long as
eff fulfilled some regularity conditions
that we're going to get to then they
exist an adaptive algorithm that obtains
uniform loss yes yes thank you for
asking because it's super important that
this is clear you know the types that
exist and you know for each iteration
the probability that each type will show
up so if you think about the
distribution being iid which it doesn't
have to be we only need independent and
even that can be relaxed somewhat but if
you think about iid you know the
probability of each arrival occurring so
you know type I shows up with
probability 1/2 and type 2
with probability 1/3 and type 3 was
probability 1/6
but the clairvoyant knows in the first
iteration type 1 shows up in the second
iteration type 3 and so forth while
making my decision I see the realization
for today yes and then there's some
feasibility constraint on that couples
the decision across periods and prevents
me from just making an optimal decision
in each period either a feasibility
constraint or something that is captured
by f so f needs not yeah accept or
reject but if you think about bin
packing
there's no accept or reject you can
think about what type of bin do I want
to put it in the objective function yeah
but you said only depends on the number
of times yes so this relation because
you take the action after realizing the
type right so the it works as follows in
iteration T we see the arrival that
occurs and we then know the type we then
take an action for this type and this
iteration we don't know all the
subsequent about think about X as being
index I should have set that more
clearly think about X as being indexed
by arrival type and action so if we have
type 1 and type 2 and accept and reject
then you should think of X as having
four indices one for except type 1 1 for
reject type 1 for one for accept type 2
1 for rejected
model clear so far
and uniform is dividing by time when I
say uniform loss no I mean my total loss
can be bounded by a constant and you
just asked a good question can you ask
it again oh yes great no I didn't use
the word efficient in here if F is
convex then it can actually give an
efficient algorithm it obtains the
uniform loss so in order to there's an
information piece here where it's
non-trivial even if we ignore
computation that we can get uniform loss
in order to get something that's
efficient
we need the convexity we need to be able
to compute an optimal solution to some
offline problem that we're going to
define now there's a lot of related work
in the last two three years with people
having found similar results for special
cases of this and it's really most
closely based to sit earlier paper with
the student a better Vera that was
mostly looking at packing problems and
in particular network revenue management
and this is really where the idea is
coming from and I'm stating here the
long literature on heuristics for
network revenue management but of course
this there's much much more that could
be cited in in this context in this sort
of of problem being studied now the
running example that I promised I'd give
is as follows we have our tea time
periods and in each time period we get
an arrival that is a dollar amount
now each amount is a payment let's say a
credit card payment that needs to be
sent to one of two firms for processing
so thank your coffee shop and people
come in and make payments and if they
order just a coffee then it's a four
dollar payment and if they order coffee
and a pastry it's a eight dollar payment
so each amount is a payment and we need
to decide whether we let square or
stripe process the payment the to the
second firm charges just a constant fee
for processing
so the second firm just says every time
a customer dissenter us we're going to
charge B dollars for processing this
payment the first firm charges the fee
that's proportional to the amount that
is being sent in this payment
but the first room also has a lower
bound of how much it's at least charging
on average over the whole time horizon
per payment sent to them in a moment I'm
going to plug in numbers to make this a
bit more tangible so let's just say our
arrivals our payments are just $10 of
$40 and we're in an iid case in which
$10 in each iteration it's a $10 payment
with probability 2/3 it's a $40 payment
with probability 1/3 from two charges
three dollars on every payment that we
sent to firm to firm one charges 10% of
the amount since if it's a $10 payment
they charge $1 if it's a $40 payment
they charge four dollars they charge 10%
but they also have a lower bound where
they say on average you will need to pay
at least two dollars per payment that we
process for you so to give an example if
we sent firm one five $10 payment and
one $40 payment then we're gonna have to
pay the maximum of 10 percent of $90
five times 10 plus 40 is 90 and six
times two dollars because on average per
payment
six dollars were sent six times two so
it will have to be at least six times
two $12 now
one thing one can do and that is sort of
standard for this online stochastic
decision-making approach is to look at
the certainty equivalent so rather than
saying $10 happens with probability 2/3
$40 happens with probability 1/3 we
could imagine an alternate scenario in
which we have things happen as an
expectation two-thirds of the time
exactly we have arrivals that are $10
payments once
we have $40 payments now in that case
it's easy to find the optimal solution
and it would be route everything to firm
one why because if we wrote everything
to firm one we our payments will be we
can basically plug two ten dollar
payments together with one $40 payment
those are three payments of worth $60
10% is $6 so we're paying exactly $2.00
per payment we cannot possibly pay less
than $2 per payment so this would be
optimal if we had the certainty
equivalent if we actually knew the
things where happening as an expectation
so reasonable heuristic the certainty
equivalent control is to say ignore
everything else that happens and just
assume things happen as in expectation
and route accordingly the problem is we
get a loss and this is from simulation
debt increases with the length of the
time horizon and that's not super
surprising if you think about how many
if you think about whether this loss
come from basically we're about square
root T away from the expectation of
what's happening over length T time
horizon so we would expect the loss to
grow in square root T and the reason for
that and this particular example would
be that if we have paid $40 payments
more than a third of the time then for
each one of these we're going to be
paying four dollars because we're
sending it to prove to firm 1 we would
be paying just 3 dollars if we were
sending them to firm 2
now next well-known heuristic is the
adaptive free solving heuristic for that
we will need a little bit of notation
think about ni as the number of arrivals
of each amount so n exit well 10 times I
so n1 will be the number of $10 payments
and 4 will be the number of $40 payments
that arrive over the full time horizon
and I of T is the forward-looking
version of this so in iteration T of the
remaining payments how many are of value
$10 how many are of $40 of course we
don't know these but for any sample path
they they exist and why I will be our
decision variable for the remaining time
horizon how many future payments of each
value do we want to route to provide a 1
and AI at this point is already constant
based on the past history how many
payments have rerouted of each value so
far to provide a 1 now the resolving
heuristic tries to minimize over Y given
history so far given the decisions that
were made and the arrivals that have
occurred so far and assuming that the
remainder of time happens as an
expectation the total amount that we're
going to be paying now we're going to be
paying $1 for each payment sent to firm
one and $3 for each pair of the
remaining payments and expectation sent
to from 2 for the $40 payments we're
going to be paying four dollars for each
one sent to firm one
three dollars for everyone center firm
two and now this one here is a bit of a
tricky expression but basically this
says if in the end will be low an
average of two dollars to a payment sent
to firm 1 this is how much we're going
to have to compensate to get to the
right amount I don't really want to go
into the detail of where this comes from
it's not a complicated expression but
the interesting bit that the resolving
heuristic then does is it says after
each payment about the payment to
provider one or in the next iteration
with probability based on the value of
the resolving eristic so if we expect a
hundred payments of value 40 dollars in
the remainder of the time horizon and we
want ten of them to be routed to firm
one and now one of them shows up then
we're going to randomize with
probability 10% we're going to send it
to provider one with probability 90% to
provider two now this is a lot better so
again this is simulated results and we
see this here was the loss of the static
policy relative to to the offline
optimal this here is the loss of the
adapter and it looks like it's really
staying very low but if we look at a
lock lock plot we actually see it's
clearly increasing at the same rate in
lock lock space as the static policy so
we still incur a loss that grows in the
square root of the time horizon relative
to the offline clairvoyant optimal
solution what we're going to find
throughout this talk is the policy down
here that actually gets a uniform loss
that does not grow with the time horizon
but not yet
first let's think a little bit more
about where the objective actually comes
from where the loss of a deferral time
horizon comes from and for that let's
think about defining an objective that
is based on running t minus 1 iterations
of the algorithm followed by the
remaining and again I haven't defined
the algorithm it but we're going to run
t minus 1 iterations of some algorithm
and thereafter we're going to let the
optimal clairvoyant take over now the
pictorial description I think is better
for this so for the first T iterations
we're letting the algorithm do whatever
does and afterwards clairvoyant will try
to optimize the remainder of time now
let us rewrite our loss as follows the
loss is the difference between algorithm
and offline algorithm it's the same as
saying offline of T running algorithm
for T minus 1 iterations and then
letting clairvoyant take over
doesn't have to be clairvoyant if
there's only one iteration left whereas
offline of 0 if we've run the algorithm
for 0 iterations then the clairvoyant is
exactly the optimal but that we can
write as a telescoping sum so we just
have the sum over all iterations of the
difference between what the the what we
would have had if we'd let the
clairvoyant take over 1 it's trivial
because if we if our objective grows as
T and even the static gets square root T
additive loss
then square root T over T goes to zero
so getting a multiplicative error of one
it's just immediate I don't know you
don't need a ID for this the the
distribution because the profit then you
don't have such thing the solution if
after them grow be T they're probably
going to give the triggers which is this
problem any multiplicative that yet
okay now what I would love to be true
are the following two properties and
those depend on the algorithm that I
choose but whatever algorithm I choose I
would love for it to be true one I don't
want to ever have a costly mistake what
do I mean by that well if you think back
to the specific problem with we're
looking at if we are sending one too
many $40 payment to firm 1 or 1 to firm
2 that should have gone to firm 1 the
cost was going to be at most one dollar
and the same is true for the for the ten
dollar payments so I want a bound over
all possible states that we could be in
in the problem doesn't have to be one
but I want to bound by a constant the
cost of a decision of the algorithm that
is not what the optima clairvoyant
wanted to do and the second one I want
to be able to say with some high
probability that actually the difference
is zero so if it's greater zero
I want it to be bounded but with high
probability I don't even want to the
algorithm to do something that the
optimal clairvoyant would not have done
as well this one in our case is easy
this one here what does with high
probability even mean well what I really
want to say is that over T iterations I
want the probabilities of this year
occurring to sum up to a constant
yes sorry the probability of this not
occurring shall sum up to a constant and
those two very easily will give me
uniform loss why because I can then say
well sum over all iterations this year
if it's greater zero then it's at most
one and then I can just sum up the
probabilities and if those sum up to a
constant
I've got uniform loss so the name of the
game is really how do we know how can we
design an algorithm that will have this
occur with high probability how do I
know how do I design an algorithm that
was high probability gives me that the
loss of a mistake the loss of doing
something that the clairvoyant would not
want to do is zero so that lets define
the notion of a disagreement so let's
call an action often of an algorithm a
disagreement exactly if it causes the
clairvoyant to have a worse objective if
the clairvoyant is following that action
let's get back to a specific problem
suppose the amount in iteration T is $40
now if it's a mistake if it's a
disagreement to send those $40 to firm
one then it must be the case that
clairvoyant wanted to send all remaining
$40 payments to firm two because
otherwise you could just swap around
otherwise you could just say oh actually
I'm gonna clairvoyant was going to send
a later payment of $40 to firm one and
not the next one but we can just swap
those two
and similarly if sending sending it to
firm to acid disagreement then the
clairvoyant must have wanted to never
again sent one to firm - it must have
wanted to send all remaining ones to
firm one so long story short the offline
optimal to have A to F a disagreement
must have never wanted to take that
action for the remainder of time now for
the specific problem let's think for a
moment about what the optimal solution
looks like the optimal solution is going
to send all ten dollar payments to
provider one why because in the best
case it's one dollar in the worst case
it's two dollars to process a ten dollar
payment through provider one and then
it's going to send the forty dollar
payments to provider one only to the
extent that it gives us an average value
of two dollars among all the payments
sent to firm one which effectively means
if there are more $40.00 if they are
more than one third of the payments for
was forty dollars then we sent exactly
half as many as we'd sent ten dollars
otherwise we sent all of them to provide
a one
[Music]
yes so let's think about the resolving
heuristic again but let's compare to
what off off line of tea does so we
basically at the same notation before
except for I introduced yio star which
is basically the solution that offline
of tea is going to use so resolving we
looked at before I don't want to
reintroduce it now what offline of tea
this was meant to be offline of tea not
opt of tea what offline of tea does is
it solve the same problem except for
rather than having the expectation for
each of the remaining arrivals it has
the exact numbers and now we're getting
close to actually the the crux of what's
happening we want to bound the
probability of a disagreement and we're
about to define the algorithm suppose
it's the case that the remaining
certainty equivalent in the resolving
heuristic the remaining payments that
are being sent to firm 1 is more than
half of the expected remaining payment
of that value what would it take to have
a disagreement in the next in the next
iteration when we're sending this meant
to be a 40 when we're sending $40 to
provider one well
the offline solution routes all $1
payments to firm 1 and for this to be a
disagreement it must be the case that it
sent all $40 payments to provider to
now from the characterization of the
offline policy on the last slide we can
get this inequality here then basically
says the offline must be able to get to
an average of two dollars overall
payment center from one without sending
without sending any more now we can
rewrite that y1 we know is always all
payments to firm one so that's just the
expected number of of these and because
we know that y 4 is greater than the
expected expectation of n 4 of T divided
by 2 we get this inequality here now
this is basically a lower bound on the
difference between n1 of T and and 4 of
T in expectation now the question is
what is the probability of a
disagreement what is the probability of
actually having a scenario where y1 star
where Y 4 star is equal to 0 because y 4
star is the number of remaining payments
being sent by the offline optimal to
provide a 1 if it's a disagreement this
here must be equal to zero so the
question is what is this probability
here and here you should be able to see
this should be exponentially unlikely
but I have things in equality because
the expectation of this here minus
something that is growing in T is
greater equal to this right hand side
the expected the probability of n1 of T
being smaller equal to the same right
hand side is really small and we could
write it out we would get something that
is exponentially small in T in the
number of remaining iterations
so that is really nice because now we
can define our algorithm finally and
it's actually almost the same as the
adaptive forest ik the only change we're
going to make will be down here so
instead of routing with the probability
we're going to set a heart threshold
where previously we set with probability
Y I divided by expectation of Ni of T we
now just say if it's greater than 1/2 do
that if it's smaller than 1/2 do the
other and we can
great so if we have that's a fair
question
is it clear that one of the two
satisfies it if we have two actions then
yes one of the two must be at least
one-half if we have three actions one of
the three must be at least one-third and
so forth they will definitely have to be
a constant and in the proof over here we
didn't really use the the two here I
thought it was more instructive to go
with the simpler example
yes basically you want to go with the
max
okay
we can then exactly bount and regret as
we've done before and we get something
that summable so we get a constant bound
on the on the loss that is incurred now
at this point I do want to highlight
that some skepticism might be in order
in particular it is well known that if
you think about the certainty equivalent
LP at iteration zero so think about just
solving the certainty equivalent over
the full time horizon that it's well
known it's impossible to compete with on
the square like to to get a uniform loss
with respective but that is not what
we're doing and this year is adapted
from a 2017 paper by Wang at all and I
think this is instructive so the
certainty equivalent LP is too weak a
benchmark so it's too strong a benchmark
the gap here is too large the offline
the clairvoyant is actually square root
additively away from the certainty
equivalent LP and that's what I drew
here so this is opt versus certainty
equivalent and what we show is that the
prophet algorithm that just thresholds
is close to that which in particular
implies that opt is also close to that
and these here have been studied for
slightly related problems for some time
in particular Raymond and Wong got
little o of square root of T but still
super constant for network revenue
management which we'll get to in a
moment as also fitting into this same
framework okay so let me be clear and
the certainty equivalent LP or expected
LP would basically be the objective that
we get when we solve the linear program
assuming that everything happens as an
expectation so yeah that is the expected
okay now that is as a benchmark to far
away from what's obtainable so on this
plot here what I did is I created a
bunch of sample paths and evaluated the
optimum and I took the average of those
Optima for each time horizon but then I
also solved the expected LP and I'm
mapping and plotting the difference
between the two and you see the
difference grows
the summative you may need to have some
additional things in addition of that
but we can get actually additive for
profit using expected MC essentially but
wondering why you cannot get there may
be additional bonds that you want to use
it yeah okay
so let's move away from our running
example and think about what we actually
used in this whole proof one thing we
definitely used was that our rivals are
concentrated around where we expect them
to be so I needed to use half things
inequality on the number of arrivals of
each type so this one is crucial the
second is I need my objective to only
depend on the number of actions taken on
each type over the full time horizon for
example it's not clear that this works
for discounting where suddenly we say if
you take the same action on the same
type in some iteration the benefit is
different from if you do it in a
different iteration and then we need two
properties about the optimal solution
and if you synthesize it down the real
properties we do we need one is simple
if we make few mistakes we don't want to
lose too much in our objective and the
other one and that one's a bit trickier
we need the optimal solutions to be
continuous in the arrivals so if it was
the case that as the arrival sequence
changes a little bit the optimal
solution changes a great deal then this
whole proof idea wouldn't work because
then we wouldn't be able to track the
optimal solution in the way the analysis
does
this one here implies the under
Lipschitz company yeah yes yes possible
to relax maybe but haven't figured it
out it so here's a sufficient condition
that turns out to be fairly general
suppose the offline problem is to
minimize the function f that is convex
lip shirts so we can compute the fluid
problem so the expected LP or the the
expected offline solution Lipschitz
so that a constant number of
disagreements does not hurt the
objective too much and has the property
and this one is a non-standard that if
we have an optimal solution for some
arrival vector N and we know that the
real arrival vector and prime is not too
far from n then we want X and X prime
then we want there to be an X prime that
is optimal that is not too far from the
other X so this is really saying under
perturbations of the arrivals the
optimal solution can change it can
change quite a bit this is almost
squared the the change in the arrivals
it cannot change too much
and the proof of sufficiency is
basically exactly the same that we had
before except for the bound on the
disagreement works slightly differently
this is a bit of a hand wavy proof but
the idea is one of the actions needs to
be linear in the remaining time horizon
this is exactly what you were asking
whether we know that one is at least one
half so finite number of actions means
one of the actions is at least linear in
the remaining time arrival time or Azzam
and then it must be exponentially
unlikely that the arrival estimates are
so far off from each other so one
example is fairly general class of
linear programs basically whenever you
can replace your constraints by
penalties which turns out you can do for
a lot of problems this will work and
it's based on theorems from the 80s
about the Lipschitz continuity of AP
optimal solutions under perturbations on
the right-hand side meaning under
perturbations in our case of of the
arrivals special cases of the LPS
include bin packing the problem that we
studied today this drop allocation one
there's a really weird scheduling
problem that I came up with that I'll be
happy to admit this very contrived
network revenue management and but
really it is actually quite general for
bin packing they certainly a cheat in
here which is that we assume that the
time horizon grows large but the
capacities of the bins are all constant
so we can enumerate over the possible
configurations of what items go into
each bin and we can make each of these
be one action
the scheduling problem yeah yes but not
with the time resin
now extensions that actually work and
are somewhat of interest one we don't
really need the samples to be mutually
independent all we need is for them to
be lets say sufficiently independent
that they're going to concentrate so
mutual independence is actually much
stronger an assumption than we need
second we don't really need to resolve
iterate every iteration because we only
need to be sure in in the proof okay
running out of time in the proof we
didn't really need point five to be the
threshold instead we could have chosen
point two five and point seven five and
as long as we know for sure that between
every two times that we resolve the
actions there are the variables
corresponding to the actions won't jump
out of this interval that would suffice
so we don't need to resolve every
iteration and this is one that I find
quite interesting we actually also don't
need the exact distribution of each the
arrivals in each iteration if we just
have a single sample path off the
arrivals over the full time horizon debt
suffices let's skip the limitation those
are negative anyway and conclude we have
a simple sufficient condition for a
uniformly bounded loss the analysis is
really quite simple the meta message
would be a threshold don't randomize and
really important to get this right is to
have the appropriate benchmark if we had
gone with the expected LP there would
have been no hope for for constant loss
and we're still working on some problems
where it's not as trivial to prove the I
want to say the interesting property of
F which is this Lipschitz continuity
under perturbations of the arrivals
thank you
[Applause]
having to take questions I'll take them
offline yes as long as I have the right
concentration on how much it's
randomized by so for example we thought
until two days ago that geometric works
and now we're pretty sure that geometric
does not work but if you give me some
bounds on how far it varies basically
the only piece that we really need is
that the number of arrivals of each type
with high probability needs to vary by
something that sub linear that is the
the key property
I think you need we need the some of the
arrival you need the basically you need
to know the state let the state I mean
for the specific problem the state yeah
you don't need the order if you think
about online knapsack you wouldn't need
to know what precise items you've
allocated you would need to know how
much of the capacity you've used already
so that is sort of the the general
justice you need to know only to the
extent that it's going to affect your
remaining decisions
[Applause]